getting ready for the first visit by a
u.s secretary of state to an illegal
israeli settlement
the sagat winery had named a blend for
mike pompeo
after he declared a year ago a change in
american policy
no longer viewing israeli settlements as
contrary to international law
it's a strong statement against all of
those
whatever core decisions and
the people around the world saying that
we are illegal
as pompeo arrived his state department
was announcing new policy
requiring all settlement-made goods to
be labeled as israeli
when entering the u.s market a
declaration of sorts
that annexed or not the u.s sees
settlements as israeli territory
this u.s administration is not biased
towards the occupation
it's a partner in the occupation we've
seen it all before
his visit didn't surprise us at all
pompeo posted photos of his tour on his
twitter
feed saying he hoped not to be the last
u.s secretary of state
to make such a visit the view from the
palestinian side
very different the city of albire is
home to a large number of dual u.s
palestinian citizens
for whom the settlement of sargot is
their stolen land
i couldn't even get close to the
settlement it would be i'll be putting
myself and anybody around me in physical
harm
so it's been since the 70s since my
family got to visit their own land
for all the controversy attached to this
visit by mike pompeo to the settlement
and for all of his talk about a possible
second trump administration
this visit to israel has had the
atmosphere of something
of a goodbye tour and that was
detectable in the statement that he
and the israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu gave in jerusalem
the two men went over a litany of trump
achievements on behalf of israel
pompeo was eager to show that the well
had not yet dried up
we will regard the global anti-israel
bds campaign as
anti-semitic i know this sounds simple
to you mr prime minister seems
it seems like a statement of fact but i
want you know that we will immediately
take steps to identify organizations
that engage
in hateful bds conduct and withdraw us
government support
the boycott divestment and sanctions
movement rebutted the accusation
saying it rejected anti-jewish racism
pompeo ended his tour
in the golan heights considered occupied
land under international law
but sovereign israeli territory by a u.s
administration
that continues to make radical shifts on
mideast policy
with just two months left in its term
harry fawcett al-jazeera
in the occupied west bank